hey guys Ryan right here and this
morning I'm going to be watching
wouldn't you know it another clip of the
amazing spider-man 2 just when you think
they're done especially when they go the
final trailer it relates an alternate
trailer 10 more TV spots and 15 more
movie clips Sony Pictures is really
concerned that no one's going to watch
this movie something gets me a little
worried like are they releasing so much
because the movie sucks so they're
trying to really sell tickets or did
they just really want to keep pumping
this up until we're sick of being pumped
up sex joke some are there watch this
thing it's the MTV exclusive OOP
blew up something Times Square safe I
believe is what it's called yeah never
with a black guy
whoa yeah oh
awesome 3d
hello
Wow spidey senses
nice is the hero
it oh man
I was a pretty sweet cle-cle p-- that
was a pretty sweet clip yeah that film
looks pretty sweet I keep
getting sick of the fact that they keep
announcing new footage and then when I
watch the footage I'm like yay that was
a great moment I love the use of
the spidey senses I remember in the
first spider-man with Tobey Maguire they
did something similar in the high school
when you fought flash but this time
they're like we're gonna amp that
segment oh so yeah that looks really
cool I'm excited to watch it I mean what
more can you say other than the fact
that this film is gonna rock your
and if you have a veg it's gonna rock
your vagina
I don't know arms with vagina that would
make sense anyway if you're new to the
channel subscribe just do it I don't
have anything else more to say now that
I talked about the subscribe button what
do you think comes next shout-out I'm
Neal Murray you requested a shout out so
Bill Murray here it is
shout out how many people call you Bill
Murray how many comment below let me
know lift raiser left a really cool
comment he said Jeremy John's the real
rejects to be following behind is like
when Conan O'Brian was following behind
that Jay Leno so it is a
compliment because there was a time
where I kind of respected Jay Leno
so thanks Bill Murray near Jackson he
threatened to kill me if I don't give
him a shout-out near Jackson a shadow
kiss don't hurt me never family never
wife and kids but my wife is getting fat
so murder her and stopping me